[موسيقى]
خط التماس بين الجيشين الروسي والاوكراني
يبقى مشتعلا في عشرات النقاط من اقصى نقطه
في الشمال عند خرك اذ الى مقاطعه خرسون
جنوبا وما بينهما وخصوصا فيزا التي تشهد
معارك ذات ابعاد استراتيجيه لا سيما في
مدينه توكماك المدينه الصغيره قريبه من
طريق رئيسي جنوب شرقي البلاد هدف القوات
الاوكرانيه السيطره على الطريق ما قد
يساعد على عزل شبه جزيره القرم عن الاراضي
الاخرى التي تسيطر عليها روسيا لكن الجيش
الروسي جاهز لاي محاوله من هذا القبيل قام
بتعزيز تحصيناته في توك ماك وبلده قريبه
منها لجعل المهمه صعبه امام الجيش
الاوكراني
ورغم التحصينات تقول القوات الاوكرانيه ان
هجمتها تحقق نجاحا وان وحداتها تتمكن من
التقدم ولو بشكل بطيء القتال في توكماك
ومقاطعه بشكل اعمم تبرز خطورته من
احتماليه توسعه الى ان الجدار حيث محطه
النوويه الرئيس الاوكراني فولوديمير
زيلنسكي قال ان جهاز الاستخبارات حصل على
معلومات تفيد بان روسيا تخطط لشن هجوم
يترتب عنه تسرب اشعاعي اما نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي
فحذر كياف من مغبه وقوع حوادث خطيره في
المحطه بسبب الهجمات التي تشنها في
الاسبوع الاول للحرب سيطرت موسكو على
المحطه النوويه الاكبر في اوروبا والعاشره
على مستوى العالم ومنذ ذلك الحين تتكرر
اته روسيا للقوات الاوكرانيه بتعمد
استهداف المحطه والمنطقه القريبه منها
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ارسلت اكثر
من مره فريقا من المراقبين وهناك ما يوجد
منهم بشكل دائم داخل المحطه التي زارها
بضع مرات رئيس الوكاله
وموسكو وعواصم غربيه والاتحاد الاوروبي
والامم المتحده جميعهم ومعهم اخرون يكررون
التحذيرات من خطوره ما يجري فيزا بوروجيا
ما يثير علامات استفهام عن هويه الجهه
التي تقصف المحطه
فقدان الثقه بين طرفي الصراع وحلفائهما
يضع ان المحطه على المحك ويعزز المخاوف من
خطر وقوع حادث نووي لن يسلم منه احد
[موسيقى]